Viele Menschen meinen: behindert –
geistig behindert.
Und sie wollen sich im Prinzip mit solchen
Menschen nicht auseinandersetzen.
Da war ich so sechs Jahre, wo ich die
Behinderung bekommen hab,
und das hat mich ja irgendwo stark gemacht.
Wenn viele sagen: „Das geht nicht!“,
dann hab ich gesagt: „Das geht.
Und das ist machbar.“
Und ich mache, ja? Und ich tue!
Auf Baustellen mit Krücken –
Alltag für Walter Stuber.
Er ist Chef und Mitinhaber
einer Gerüstbaufirma.
Wo wir vor 19 Jahren das Unternehmen
übernommen haben von dem Altbesitzer,
war ich der Einzige, wo behindert war.
Ich war aber dortmals runtergerechnet also
um die 40, ja, hatte vorher
das Unternehmen, das Altunternehmen,
hier in Sachsen schon
ungefähr zehn Jahre geleitet.
Die Banken sind natürlich grundsätzlich
vorsichtiger bei Behinderten,
weil sie nicht mehr wissen:
Können die das Geld überhaupt, was sie mal
genommen haben, zurückzahlen?
Viele, wo ich kenne,
die ähnliche Behinderungen haben,
sind heute schon im Rollstuhl.
Und da sind natürlich die
Banken sehr vorsichtig:
Kann der unser Geld noch
langfristig zurückzahlen?
Es folgen schwierige Jahre, in denen er
insgesamt 400 Mitarbeiter vergrault.
Ich war früher ein Tyrann,
ja, zu meinen Mitarbeitern.
Das größte Problem war einfach:
Ich musste mich behaupten.
Und behaupten habe ich mich damit gekonnt,
dass ich natürlich meinen Mitarbeitern
zeigen musste, wer der Chef ist.
Teilweise tut mir’s leid.
Ich bin mit der Wasserwaage durchgegangen,
hab geschaut, ob das gerad’ steht,
und wenn das nicht gerad’ gestanden hat,
dann hat’s sein können,
dass er den Arbeitsplatz verloren hat.
So weit ist das gegangen.
Also, ich musste mich
aufgrund auch meiner Erziehung,
weil ich immer ’n bisschen so
auch in der Erziehung… nach … von
meinen Eltern so [kleingehalten wurde]:
„Ja, du bist behindert, du kannst das nicht!“
Und so musste ich mich halt immer beweisen:
Was? Ich kann das, ich will das!
Mittlerweile müssen seine Mitarbeiter
ihn nicht mehr fürchten.
Stuber wurde milder,
seit er sich erfolgreich etabliert hat.
Also entscheidend war,
mal richtig auf die Nase zu fallen, ja.
Also, das muss ich so sagen.
Und dann zu sagen:
Hey, ich hab hier
richtig Scheiße gebaut.
Also, 2010 hatten wir
’nen Auftrag angenommen.
Da haben wir uns [um[ 300.000 verkalkuliert.
Und 2012 ... 14, in den Jahren haben wir
uns komplett noch mal neu aufgestellt.
Die Firma hat sich im Spezialgerüstbau
einen Namen gemacht.
Stuber hofft, Vorbild für andere zu sein,
denn Unternehmer mit Handicap gibt
es in Deutschland so gut wie gar nicht.
Ich glaube, dass Menschen
mit Handicap grundsätzlich, ja,
mehr in die Öffentlichkeit
gerückt werden müssen.
Also nicht unterstützen, sondern mehr
in die Öffentlichkeit gerückt werden.
Menschen, die ein Handicap haben,
wann sehen Sie die in der Zeitung?
Wann sehen Sie die im Fernsehen?
Fast nie, ja?
Und da liegt das große Problem,
dass die sich teilweise auch nicht trauen,
nach vorne zu gehen und zu sagen:
„Hier bin ich, ich hab ’n Problem,
aber ich bin so weit geistig fit,
dass ich ein Unternehmen aufbauen kann.“
Stuber versucht, immer positiv zu denken.
Erlittene Diskriminierungen aufgrund
seines Handicaps blendet er aus.
Die hat’s auch gegeben, ja.
Die waren teilweise auch schlimm,
aber es ist nicht so,
dass ich mir jetzt die
im Hinterkopf gemerkt habe.
Und es kommt dazu: Ich komm langsam
über die 60 und ich merke halt doch,
dass manche Sachen, manchmal unwichtige
Sachen, aus dem Speicher rausfliegen.